[Musik]
ich begrüße sie liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer sie hörten den klang einer
friedensglocke einer psp die mein
heutiger gast eigenhändig aus krieg
schrott gegossen hat mit diesem klang
stimmt er sonst seine konzerte ein er
ist in vielfacher hinsicht ein
außergewöhnlicher mensch ein musiker ein
gott suchen michael patrick king ein
mann mit drei leben in seinem ersten
leben wurde mit der legendären
musikgruppe kelly family zum kinderstar
einer ganzen teenager generation auf dem
höhepunkt seiner karriere bricht partie
wie man ihn liebevoll nannte
mit allem und zieht sich zurück in ein
schweige kloster in frankreich dieses
zweite leben dauert sechs jahre dann
kommt er wieder zurück zurück mit einem
dritten lebensmut
wer ist nun michael petri kelly im
heutigen gespräch möchte ich mit ihm
über seine drei leben sprechen lieber
religionen musik über glaube liebe und
hoffen ich freue mich auf dieses
gespräch lieber michael patrick vielen
dank für die einladung sehr netten
einzelne wort
sie starten den tag eigentlich jeden
morgen mit einem gebet dafür sie fragen
für sie heute gebetet haben also ich
fange mein tag immer mit mit einem danke
an also ist das einfach so dass ich mich
bei gott bedanken dass ich atme dass ich
lebe dass ich einen neuen tag geschenkt
bekommen und bitte einfach auch
für demut und dass ich auch höhere auf
menschen auf natur auf die ereignisse
weil für mich spricht gott in erster
linie über die realität und das ist
nämlich immer sehr spannend zu wissen
welche realität werde ich heute erfahren
und deswegen freue ich mich sehr auf
unser gespräch ja schön weil ihr vater
war iris katholisch die mutter
protestantisch wie haben sie diese
interreligiöse beziehungen eigentlich
vorgenommen das interessante ist ich
wurde gar nicht sehr religiös erzogen
dass es wurde zu hause nicht redet oder
bibel gelesen oder ab und zu ging man
auch in die kirche aber ich war ja so
einen vagabunden lifestyle und deswegen
hatte man nicht diese regel alle
teams wie andere leute mit schule und
mit sonntags zur kirche oder keine
ahnung freizeit am wochenende
von daher ist es bei mir eher sehr spät
ist ein interesse für religion für
glaube für existenzielle fragen erweckt
worden und durch eine persönliche
entscheidung also es war gar nicht so
dass nicht von oben mit bekommen habe
und das war einfach ein persönliches
interesse
dann findet das interesse eigentlich an
denn wenn man bedenkt sie haben mit 15
ein welthit geschrieben
angels das ist wirklich
bemerkenswert
wie kommen sie dazu ja also ich denke
man kann sich das ein bisschen so
vorstellen wie in so einer zirkusfamilie
man wird einfach hinein geboren und
sieht wie die älteren geschwister da so
simulieren oder irgendwelche akkupacks
machen und dann will man als kleines
kind einfach das auch und so fink bei
mir mit der musik einfach sehr sehr früh
an also ich habe musik quasi mit der
muttermilch aufgesaugt und ist ja meine
zweite natur geworden und so habe ich
mit neuen rätseln angefangen weil
erstens songs zu schreiben und ich haben
sehr viele songs geschrieben und
damit 15 kamen dann dieses eine lied was
auch wirklich viele türen geöffnet hat
und
ich hab keine formel nicht ich glaube
ich jeder künstler würde sich wünschen
zu wissen wie es geht
einen tollen hits zu schreiben aber
ich finde der sänger von coldplay hat es
sehr schön gesagt sagen dann kam
france kam kurs also man redet von
inspiration kommt irgendwas ist zu
ungenau
aber warum angels warum inkl das für
eine beziehung haben sie eigentlich zu
den enkel also ich hatte einen traum in
dem ich
engel gesehen habe der einfach ja frei
herumfliegen konnte und dass das fand
ich so so schön und das war so eine
sehnsucht ich wünschte ich könnte das
auch ich wünschte ich wäre wie du und
ich glaube diese sehnsucht hat viele
menschen einfach ins herz gesprochen
weil es gibt viele menschen die aus
ihrer situation raus wollen und
wegfliegen und ja das ist aber ich habe
jetzt nicht wirklich so wie soll ich
sagen henkel erscheinungen gehabt oder
sie also doch zum glück so gut so heilig
wie dich
ja ich meine wenn sie als auch
angesprochen wenn wir uns an atrium
ersten leben kurz zu wenden
wenn man dieses leben genauer betrachtet
dann scheint es so zu sein dass diese
keinen festen rhythmen kennt sie sind
einfach in einer großfamilie
aufgewachsene musiker familie den
straßen musik gemacht hat mit toren und
konzert und später auch noch unterwegs
war was dann familienbewusstsein haben
sie eigentlich heute
also meine eltern waren
sehr außergewöhnliche menschen also mein
vater war lehrer dann hat der politik
gemacht dann war antiquitätenhändler
unternehmer er war ein visionär und er
liebte kunst philosophie und meine
mutter war
tänzerin ballerina und spielte klavier
und die hatten beide diesen traum
als singende familie die welt zu
bereisen und versuchen den menschen
freude und hoffnung zu bringen das war
so ein bisschen diese stream denn sie
hatten und und dann hat mein vater
irgendwann einen doppeldecker bus
gekauft und da stand drauf the world ist
also nicht ob meier home is my castle
sondern die welt ist unser schloss so
und und wer war auch sehr geprägt von
diesem buch von jack kerouac und rot und
da steht irgendwo wieder frieden und
freiheit war ein großes thema für ihn er
wollte frei leben und seine kinder frei
erziehen also ich bin nie zur schule
gegangen mein vater hat homeschooling
gemacht lange bevor die pandemie ist in
europa legalisiert hat deswegen sind wir
auch viel rumgereist weil homeschooling
nicht überall erlaubt war und meine
frage ist ja gerade das war was für
einen sinn der familie wird hier
vermittelt und so sehen sie auch etwas
kritisches im rückblick heute wo die
sagen
das war unglaublich schön also das
wollen sie in gewisser weise auch nicht
wissen weil auch die sie zu dem gemacht
ist weil sie heute sind ja aber es
zugleich gibt es vielleicht auch ein
kritisches moment
also ich glaube kritisch also einerseits
positiv würde ich sagen gab es einen
sehr starken familien halt wir waren
wirklich alle sehr one und die musik war
das verbindende element und aber
kritisch gesehen würde ich sagen
vielleicht war das manchmal zu sehr in
sich selbst kreisen also dass man nicht
wirklich viele andere soziale kreise
hatte sondern stamm lieberman und
und das geht glaube ich irgendwann auch
gegen die natur weil jeder dann
irgendwann seine eigene family auch
aufbauen will und seine individualität
und persönliches gut vor dem gemeingut
stellen möchte und das war vielleicht
ein ein kritischer punkt wo ich sagen
würde vielleicht wäre es gut gewesen
dass man eine alternative zur schule
befindet es gab immer freunde und kinder
die zu uns kamen weil sie das einfach
faszinierend fanden aber ja und dass man
einfach auch viel unterwegs war
lange bevor es what's up und e mail gab
also da konnte man keine freundschaften
wirklich also langfristige
freundschaften pflegen
aber ich glaube kein leben ist perfekt
man kann nicht alles haben ich bin im
großen ganzen sehr dankbar für dieses
töne trifft way of life denn meine
eltern mir mitgegeben haben und
etwas später als der große erfolg der
90er kam das war schon das war wirklich
teilweise erschreckend wenn sie tausende
von teenager kids da so mit diesen hohen
frequentierten stimmen schreien
muss man immer damit umgehen so und gab
schon momente wo ich ein bisschen
überfordert war ja das glaube ich glaube
auch die familie so wie ich es sie
erlebe auch in ihrer vita sehen
öffentliche person es sieht nicht so aus
als hätten sie ein
eine wiederholung dieses familien
bewusstseins vor dass sie so eine
familie auch weiter tradieren wollen
sondern sie nehmen so wie sie war das
positive heraus aber sind scheint auch
in ein anderes bild der familie auch für
sich gewonnen zu haben ja also es ist
interessant weil es
gibt ja freunde von mir also mein bester
freund zum beispiel
teilen nicht die gleichen gene aber es
gibt sachen die erzähle ich nur ihm die
erzähle ich kein meiner geschwister und
oder oder meine frau ich glaube man kann
mit menschen die nicht die gleichen gene
teilen mehr vereint sein als mit
biologische
grundlagen
nicht desto trotz gibt es innerhalb
meiner familie auch freunde also
geschwister die ich als freunde sehe
aber
ich glaube familie sucht man sich nicht
aus freunde schon und ich bin für beides
dankbar also wirklich
man sie haben ihre eltern sind
verstorben übermutter haben sie mit fünf
jahren verloren
ich glaube es sehr schlecht formuliert
wurde kann man kann man deine mutter
verlieren
das ist eine gute frage
ich glaube schon also ich glaube nicht
dass man ein tod schönreden kann es ist
ein buch es ist eine
einem mangel eine lehre wie dann
entsteht und ich habe eigentlich wenige
memories von meiner mutter aber es gibt
sehr viele video und fotoaufnahmen von
ihr und ich habe sehr viel von meinem
vater von meinen geschwistern
mitbekommen und vor kurzem
habe ich auch tagebücher von ihr
gefunden und hab mich da rein gelesen
und das ist so spannend weil jetzt
entdecke ich meine mutter auf eine art
und weise die ich vorher nicht kannte
und das sind sehr sehr private intime
themen über die sie sich auch also
schreibt und auch viel über ihre glaubt
zwar eine sehr gläubige frau was ich so
nicht wusste also sehr sehr tief gläubig
und das ist schön dass das man da
einfach ein vielleicht echtes bild von
seiner mutter bekommt weil die
performance des on stage sind
darstellende kunst und da gibt man in
der regel sein westhoff aber auch mal
schwächen zu sehen oder zweifel oder
sorgen ängste
das ist sehr interessant
bei denen bei den tagebüchern haben sie
etwas irgendwo sich selbst wieder
entdeckt eine eigenschaft seine
innenwelt die sie bei ihrer mutter
verschiedene ja tatsächlich es gibt ein
paar aspekte also man merkt dass sie
einfach ein herz hatte was anderen
menschen einfach liebe schenken möchte
und da finde ich mich ein bisschen
lieder ohne mich jetzt irgendwie
als toller mensch da hinzustellen aber
ich will einfach dass es an einem
menschen gut geht und zwar ist durch die
musik sei es in meinem freundeskreis
wenn ich merke hey da geht es 1 grad
nicht gut oder dann möchte ich für diese
personen da sein und ich versuche aber
ich es gelingt bin ich immer und und das
hatte sie und vielleicht kommt das von
ihr das andere ist ihr tiefer glaube an
gott also an auch in jesus und ich
wusste nicht dass sie so eine betende
frau war also wirklich jeden tag auch
gebetet und in ihren tagebüchern dialog
mit gott auch so geführt und es ist
interessant was ich fand das sehr
spannend
es war bewegend ist gerade sehr schlecht
oder sie da sitzen lesen und absolut der
aktuell augenblicke total also aktuell
beschäftigt mich das thema vertrauen
sehr und man merkt auch in ihren
tagebüchern das dass das für sie sie war
ja in vielen
also meine mutter war in vieler hinsicht
auch überfordert bei so vielen kindern
und jeder kommt zu kurz und dann gibt es
da ein problem und ihren problemen und
dann reißt man von a nach b und dann für
formen cez und und ja das dass man lernt
zu vertrauen in situation wo man nicht
weiter weiß dass man diesen
vertrauensvorschuss gibt das ist etwas
was ich sehr spannend finde und da bin
ich noch schüler
sie haben wir auch ihr ein lied gewidmet
in ihren neuen album boots mit dem
schönen titel mother lassen sie uns
einen kurzen ausschnitt gerne
[Musik]
dort haben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja welche geschichte zählen also mein
album boots das sind die initialen für
based on a true story und jeder song
basiert auf einer wahren geschichte und
die geschichte dieses liedes ist dass
ich ein halbes jahr nachdem meine mutter
starb
zum muttertag einfach blumen bringen
wollte und
ich kann am friedhof an und hatte nur so
ein paar feld blumen mitgebracht die ich
da auf dem weg dahin gepflegt hatte und
dann stellte ich fest dass alle anderen
grabsteine tolle blumenstrauß sträuße
stellte ich fest dass die anderen gräber
tolle blumensträuße hatten und dann habe
ich einfach als fünfjähriger junge alle
blumen geklaut und auf das grab meiner
mutter gelegt und diese bilder die wir
gesehen haben dass war die
wiedergutmachung also da bin ich mit
diesem pick up shop hingefahren um das
wieder gut zu machen weil ich glaube als
kind meint dies gut aber es hat nicht
immer mein gewissen ein bisschen
gekratzt dass ich diese frau ist geklaut
haben und die leute im dorf war ein sehr
sehr gerührt und auch geweint und ja
jetzt ist der kreis irgendwie
geschlossen und darüber halle dieses
lied
von roger williamson ist der schöne
gedanke überliefert dass er einmal sagte
die erste religion der menschheit ist
die mutterliebe
können sie ihm zustimmen
ich glaube schon dass es
in vielen tatsächlichen
archäologischen funde gibt es ja auch
also
mutterschaft fruchtbarkeit ist ja in
vielen naturreligionen auch ein großes
thema und es bleibt für uns menschen
glaube ich auch irgendwie ein mystery
wie leben entsteht und dann in so einem
moment da so wächst und dann rauskommt
ich glaube man muss man muss realistisch
sein man darf den mutter nicht
vergöttern verehren ja aber so an finde
ich übertrieben weil eine mutter ist
auch nur ein mensch und auch ermordung
nicht immer aber ich verstehe dieses ja
das ist die erste person von der man
liebe bekommt leben bekommt und auch die
ersten zwei drei jahre
zwischen mutter und kind ist eine sehr
wichtige zeit für die
psychologischen fundament des lebens
wenn diese bindung nicht da ist dann
merkt man dass es menschen gibt genau
das was sie am meisten interessiert
gerade wenig vertrauen ja es ist das was
sagen die mutter perse verkörpert ja ja
schon bewegend lassen sie uns zu ihrem
zweiten leben übergeben ganz brachial
der bedeutende muslimische theologe al
ghazali aus dem elften und zwölften
jahrhundert berichtet selbst dass er
nachdem er großen ruhm und anerkennung
und würdigung erfahren hat
dann plötzlich eine tiefe lehrer in die
spürte eine tiefe krise gestürzt ist in
einer art 7 armut und hat keinen
gefallen an irgend etwas gefunden was er
sonst gerne getan hat was passiert mit
ihm er kann seinen mund nicht mehr
öffnen er kann nicht mehr sprechen
ich kann nichts mehr essen nicht mehr
trinken was macht er er bricht mit allem
und verlässt sein lehrtätigkeit seine
rom seine familie und begibt sich auf
eine spirituelle reise keine zehn jahre
kommt ihm die geschichte bekannt vor
da sind ein paar parallelen tatsächlich
sich kenne diesen theologen nicht aber
das was sie berichten
kommt mir tatsächlich bekannt vor ich
hatte mit anfang 20 mit mit der familie
ein wahnsinnserfolg erlebt und und
stadien gespielt und lebte in ein
schloss und
ja alles wovon viele menschen träumen
hatte ich mit sehr jungen jahren schon
alles
gibt und trotzdem merkte ich dass da so
eine große leere da ist und dass man
etwas was man glück nennt oder frieden
nennt nicht im supermarkt kaufen kann
oder mit noch mehr autos noch mehr
goldene schallplatten so das hat mich
auf der suche nach mehr gebracht mehr im
sinne von den sinn von von von gott von
von glück von frieden und das war meine
spirituelle suche wie hat sich diese
leere angefühlt
furchtbar furchtbar ja ja das ist es ist
so als würde man leben aber nicht
existieren kann man nix also es ist so
als würde man existieren aber nicht
leben man ist
also man
atmet man ist man aber ist man ist wie
tot so ist es einfach so alles
verwirrend
sinnlos und verzweifelt und und und dann
ja ich weiß ich kann vielleicht von
depression reden von von
seelisches leid oder so und dann möchte
man einfach raus und es ist interessant
weil ich hatte in der zeit eine
dokumentation im fernsehen gesehen über
einen marienwallfahrtsort und frankreich
gesehen wird wo sechs millionen pilger
jedes jahr hingehen und ich dachte erst
das ist nur für omas ja und was soll ich
da mit halleluja und ich bin doch ein
popstar aber es war wie ein magnet das
hat mich so hingezogen und dann hab ich
mich auf den weg gemacht und bin dahin
und und da habe ich zum ersten mal
wirklich frieden gespürt und
das war schwer zu beschreiben aber ich
habe frieden
gespürt und das war wie so erfüllend
diese lehre wurde mit diesen frieden
voll und und da habe ich angefangen zu
beten habe ich den rosenkranz gekauft
und da habe ich angefangen einfach jeden
tag erstmal drei perlen und dann wohl
szenen und irgendwann was die hose und
das gab mir frieden das gab mir ruhe und
peace auch dieses repetitive hat ja was
klar ist
dass wie findet man ihn achtung kloster
schweige kloster eigentlich frieden also
ich habe schwierigkeiten hier ruhig zu
sitzen ich glaube hier habe ich ganz
groß geschrieben nicht wackeln
sonst bin ich einfach unruhe jetzt in
die daher ich will sie verstehen wie
finden sie also hatte ich die diesen
frieden plötzlich eingestellte den dort
in einem anderen stimmung in eine andere
lebenswelt und das hat sie so seien
gepackt oder hat sich das allmählich
entwickelt es war ein prozess es war ein
prozess also mit anfang 20 hatte ich ja
diese krise so und dann habe ich auch
eine psychotherapie gemacht so
eineinhalb jahre also heute spricht man
unter jungen menschen viel mehr über
mental health und sollte es aber damals
jemand erzählt ich geh zum therapeuten
wenn ihr so etwas mit dir los
jedenfalls war das ein ein weg um zu
versuchen ordnung und keine irgendwie
mein leben zu sortieren und das andere
war der interesse im glauben und
religion und ich habe auch den koran in
der englischen übersetzung gelesen und
habe nicht ein bisschen mit buddhismus
beschäftigt und dann vor allem mit der
bibel dann bin ich einfach in klöster
gegangen und habe nach einer quelle
gesucht und das war so ein prozess von 3
4 bis 5 jahren und
jedes mal wenn ich also orte war spürte
ich diesen frieden diese diese ruhe die
sind dieses glück was man nicht auf
amazon bestellen kann wie kann man sich
diese schweigen vorstellen also haben
sie wirklich dann die ganze zeit war das
mit dem schweigegelübde
abgelegt haben oder also dass das also
das kloster das kloster dass ich dann
2004 eingetreten bin war ein schweige
kloster im sinne dass man so zweieinhalb
tage pro tag 2
also in kloster gab es zweieinhalb
stunden pro tag wo still gebetet und
meditiert wurde und sonst hat man
tagsüber auch nicht viel gesprochen es
war also ein schweige kloster und die
ersten monate waren für mich sehr sehr
schwierig weil ich kam ja von einem
popstar lifestyle so ein nobody und
einfach still und schweigen und hören
und das schöne an der stelle ist dass
man also ich war ein sehr ich war vor
der klosterzeit ein sehr extrovertierter
mensch aber sorry ich running on waves
jumping oder running to something also
ich war immer auf der flucht so aber nie
wirklich bei mir oder in mir und dass
das hat geholfen einfach erstmal
irgendwie anzukommen und sowie der
griechische philosoph sokrates sagt
erkenne dich selbst ne news auf und ich
musste mich erst mal kennenlernen wer
bin ich so und dann wenn du steigst wenn
du da an der kapelle einfach stundenlang
sitzt oder knies oder stehst dann hörst
du erstmal in dich hinein es ist nicht
alles los und da sind irgendwie kein
anderes ist ein bisschen wie tauchen
gehen ja eine schöne chorale hero dies
aber tod ja oder guck mal hier ist eine
alte plastikflaschen
das können wir jetzt mal weg oder
unschöne schildkröte so ist das wenn man
so wissen in sich hinein hört man findet
schönes und nicht so schöne
erinnerungen oder projektionen die
zukunft ängste sorgen wünsche sehnsüchte
also
diese welt mal zu entdeckende inside the
story of human being das ist ein prozess
der jahre braucht und ich hatte auch
sehr viel zu verarbeiten
also die ersten monate wie gesagt waren
sehr schwer einfach fünf minuten still
zu sitzen
ich bin immer und heute noch ein opfer
von aktivismus doing something so dieses
augoustinos sagt
renate rest an touristen die augustinus
sagt nun ich werde nicht ruhen bis ich
in die ruhe und das bezogen auf gott und
ich hab dich so hohe besucht und war
sehr rastlos und es hat ein paar jahre
gebraucht aber irgendwann kam diese hohe
und das macht sich
ausnahmsweise
sie haben gerade gesagt hat habe sie
gesprochen dann würde er das haben
orakelt von delphi diese in diesen
spruch liest und davon tief beeindruckt
ist wie alle anderen natürlich athener
auch die die sich damit beschäftigen
meine frage wäre wen haben sie erkannt
wenn sie sich selbst erkannt haben
ich würde die frage so beantworten
ich glaube bis ich gott als realität
begegnet bin und ich meine das jetzt
nicht im spooky sind ja so ich habe gott
gesehen sondern wirklich so realistische
wahrnehmung von einer gegenwart die
unsichtbar ist aber die da ist war ich
wie so ein waisenkind ich wusste nicht
wo ich herkomme wo ich hingehe warum es
nicht gibt
ich bin ja songwriter und jeder song hat
ein songwriter und wenn ich mich jetzt
selber als es einen song verstehe oder
als ein werk ein kunstwerk dann kann ich
mich selbst nur verstehen wenn ich den
erfinder frage oder kennenlernen und so
hey was hast du dir dabei gedacht so als
du mich geschrieben hast und so würde
ich das beschreiben also ich glaub man
merkt dass bei waisenkindern die nicht
wissen wer ihre biologischen eltern sind
die manche wollen es wissen weil sie
wollen wissen wo komme ich her was habe
ich für jene wer ist mein vater ist
meine mutter und so war es bei mir mit
mit gott ich wollte wissen
aber um sich wirklich selber zu finden
muss man
glaube ich den urheber den den autor den
erfinder den schöpfer seiner seele
finden und das hat ja diese sechs jahre
haben mir diese antwort gegeben und es
ist so schön das tut so gut wenn man das
erleben darf
lieber mal glück patrick hat das
schweigen eine melodie
sehr viele sogar sehr viele wie klingt
ja ich glaube ist manche manches also
meine songs sind
oft glaube ich aus dieser quelle der
stille entstanden es ist interessant
weil mein beruf als musiker ist hier
eine wo man töne klänge laute von sich
gibt uns viele diese songs kommen aus
der stille aus der aus das genaue
gegenteil
das ist für mich eine quelle von
inspiration also ich nehme jeden tag
eine halbe bis dreiviertelstunde stille
zeit also stilles gebet so
und das ist das tut sehr sehr gut so das
habe ich aus dieser bloßer zeit in
meinem heutigen alltag mit rübergenommen
aber es ist manchmal auch schwer still
zu sein man kann die keine ahnung die
gedanken dann ist vielleicht so sinnlich
gesehen still aber innen drin ist ja
auch viel neues
sie waren ein mensch sie haben auch
einen neuen namen bekommen
wo ist er
also was ein mensch charakterisiert ist
dass es jemand ist der gott sucht und
das ist geblieben also ich glaube wenn
man
gott findet oder sich finden lässt von
gott
bleibt es trotzdem ging bronze das ist
wie in einer beziehung wie in einer ehe
mein mann liebt jemand man kennt jemand
aber über die jahre lernt man auch neue
aspekte und facetten kennen und so ist
es wenn ich auch ihre gottesbeziehung
dieses unglaubliche mysterium ist ja
ohne unerschöpflich und ich nenne gott
den unsichtbaren regisseur meines lebens
[Gelächter]
schönes bild
welcher teil von ihm ist immer noch im
kloster und schweigt
wahrscheinlich der der tiefste teil von
mir also
es gibt einen song das heißt happiness
und da gibt es eine zeile erfahrungen
die in der table wird eternity ich habe
die innere kammern gefunden in der die
ewigkeit
echoes hinterlässt
das ist nach wie vor da also dass ich
hab' ich wohne nicht mehr in einer
klosterzelle aber ich habe in mir so was
wie der klosterzelle mitgenommen
und heute ich finde auch gott dem
showbusiness ja oder keine ahnung einer
tankstelle also ist ich finde wir leben
in gott wie fische im wasser sie merken
es nicht schwimmen einfach so rum aber
das ist dieses klick dieses bewusst
werden von liza usa eine islam ins auge
ist sehr das ist das ist mein glück also
da ist
ein sieg über dieses mal kritisch
nachfragen da war ich glaube sie sind
selbst ein sehr kritischer geister
erlaube ich mir dies der weg zum
menschsein das ist ja auch diese
gewählte armut diese gewählt
wenig sein sie haben von nobody sein
also niemand sein wollen weniger lärm
hören hat ja auch etwas
luxuriöses das kann ja auch dich nicht
jeder leisten in frankreich ein kloster
sich zurückzuziehen und frieden zu
finden
war das ein thema für sie dass sie sich
auch
das wo findet man heute
ja definitiv also ich es gibt einen satz
von jesus wo er sagte hoyos 11 1 teams
auf und ich musste mich quasi verlieren
oder
loslassen abgeben aufgeben um wirklich
sich selbst zu finden und
ja ich denke
manchmal muss man irgendwie zu sich
sterben um neu geboren zu werden sowieso
eine raupe die irgendwann zum
schmetterling wird und das kloster war
wie eine lawine sagt man dass
geburtshelferin oder so
das kloster war für mich wie eine
hebamme ja der diese wiedergeburt diese
neue geburt stattfinden konnte und auch
die des musikers das interessante ist
ich war bis kurz vor der klosterzeit
hatte ich die leidenschaft musik fast
komplett verloren und in der klosterzeit
haben die älteren menschen mir empfohlen
musik zu machen ich wollte komplett
nicht alles abschließen nein nein mach
doch wenigstens eine stunde in der woche
musik und da habe ich die freude an
kunst und musik neu geschenkt bekommen
weil es zwecks frei war es war es nicht
schön radiohit oder für eine tournee
oder sondern es war einfach der freude
will und da das war für mich auch ja die
wiedergeburt des musikers und da bin ich
sehr dankbar für ich war vor kurzem
tatsächlich in frankreich in diesem
kloster wo ich ein noviziat war und war
dann in diesem keller wo ich sonntags
dieses songs geschrieben haben das war
sehr sehr schöner moment da noch mal hin
zu gehen und zu sehen wo ja die die
geburts stelle des musikers
wahr und es ist also ich mache so ein
zwei mal im jahr so drei bis fünf tage
schweige tage also einkehrtage in
klöster und
schaltet das handy aus und die offline
aber die online rot
beleuchteten an sogar
[Gelächter]
ganz andere wlan ein schickes anderer
weg als
sie wieder dort waren haben sie eine
veränderung gespürt
waren sie denn gleiche von damals
natürlich das getan er hat sich ja also
ich bin nicht mehr der gleiche der das
war schon sehr interessant bekommt viele
memories hoch also mir kamen auch die
tränen weil es einfach sehr intensive
jahre waren sehr besondere momente aber
auch schwere momente sie sprachen vorhin
von verzicht und es war wirklich eine
zeit wo man auf viel verzichten mussten
also angefangen mit dem zölibat leben ja
oder keine konzerte zu geben oder nicht
wann und wie man will einfach zu reisen
sondern man ordnet sich eine regler die
vita unter und lebt mit 60 70 menschen
aus 25 nationalitäten manchem mag man
manchmal mag man gar nicht ja also das
ist ja auch wie so ein sack kartoffeln
in dem man so sich aneinander reibt und
aber es war eine großartige zeit von der
ich bis heute sehr sehr viele und ich
bin auch nach wie vor mit manche dieser
menschen von damals befreundet und einer
von denen aus meinem jahrgang schickt
jeden morgen so what's up mit so impulse
das ein tag mit zur bibelstellen und
wenn ich zähne putze dann höre ich mir
das an und das ist gestartet ja ja die
frage sagen die frage ist was hat sie
aus dem kloster herausgebracht
ja es ist
ich bin in den letzten zwei jahren sehr
auf krank geworden er ist war es eine
grippe oder erkältung und dann hatte ich
eine chronische erschöpfung monatlich in
videos eine bakterie also one thing of
canada und die älteren menschen haben
das so als zeichen interpretiert
die haben gesagt 'junge in der regel
spricht gott über die realität und die
realität ist dass dein körper hier nicht
mitmacht und du bist kein engel du bist
ein mensch und mensch besteht aus körper
und seele und geist also
go go girl gebäck music ingolf gar das
waren sozusagen die empfehlung und es
fiel mir anfangs sehr schwer zu
akzeptieren dass ich nicht bleiben
konnte im nachhinein bin ich dankbar für
diese einsicht weil ich bin so liricher
dickkopf ich will dann wie so ein
captain mit dem schiff sinken ja
das war eigentlich ja sehr sehr schlaufe
diesen menschen ja mehr erfahrungen mit
dieser leben als ich man muss dazu
berufen sein ich glaube nicht dass jeder
mensch ins kloster muss um sich selbst
zu finden oder gott zu finden oder den
sinn des lebens zu finden aber
ab und zu
offline gehen und sich bei gott
einloggen kann nicht schaden also mir
tut's unfassbar gut
sie werden sich auch große themen zu das
kann man glaube ich gut sagen auf jeden
neuen album sind große themen hoffnung
liebe glaube alle sind sehr präsent aber
dennoch
erzählen sie die großen themen am echten
spürbare menschen und mir scheint es
dass sie auch natürlich auch vielfach
auch sagen dass ich ein unbändiger liebe
für die menschen empfinden
und das nervt mich unglaublich
ich finde sie hassen
da können sie das nur natürlich bin ich
auch ein humanist und und liebe menschen
weil es um sein soll aber es ist auch
etwas ganz ungeheuerlich ist ein mensch
zu sein
hat das was mit ihrem glauben zu tun
darauf will ich hinaus hat das was mit
damit zu tun dass jesus dass gott mensch
geworden ist in der gestalt von jesus
von nazareth und dieses bild sich bei
ihnen so eingeprägt hat dass sie an ihm
sozusagen die menschheit begünstigt
lieben
das was sie sagen das ist die antwort
sie haben die frage gestellt und die
antwort gegeben es ist merkt man sich
diese üben
wissen sie was nicht dabei sozusagen
in unverständnis zurücklässt ist ich
kann nicht an einen gott glauben
er wäre nicht geworden ist
gerade das ist der punkt aber ich liebe
das christentum das christentum ist ein
unglaublich tief greifende und wenn sie
so wollen theologisch logisch
nachvollziehbare
aber wäre nur ein gerät nicht mensch
gemacht
und dieser mensch werde also das wo sie
begrenzt die quelle ihres glauben
schöpfen ihre liebe für die menschheit
ja das ist vielleicht schon vor dem
hintergrund meiner biografie kriegs
gehen was auch jemand ist ist gestartet
und ich frage mich wie wie können sie
noch an den menschen glauben der
natürlich viel unheil stiftet durfte
sich ehrlich natürlich also diese fragen
hatte ich mit anfang 20 also ich hatte
auch an die existenz gottes
gezweifelt weil ich habe wenn es einen
gott gibt wie kann er so viel schlimmes
erlauben hier was auf erden los ist und
nicht einfach zu beantwortende frage
wie soll ich sagen ich
selber hab meine eigenen grenzen
entdeckt meine eigenen schwächen ich
habe auch viele dummheiten gemacht ich
habe vielleicht fast alle zehn gebote
mehrmals gebrochen ja und dass ich
trotzdem
geliebt werde ja das ist zum beispiel
ein freund ein echter freund kennt dich
und liebt dich trotzdem das ist etwas
mehr hoffnung gibt und das ist was ich
in jesus finde petrus hat ihn geleugnet
das hat ihn verraten und ist da gekreuzt
und sagt vater vergib ihnen denn sie
wissen nicht was sie tun also er nimmt
auch die menschliche schwäche an und wir
müssen nicht perfekt und gerecht sein um
geliebt zu werden das ist was mich total
an zieht bei jesus weil ich merke ich
kann auch ein verbrecher sein aber wenn
ich das
bekenne und nicht
wende dann dann dann kann ich dieses
grace bekommen der vergebung und es gibt
einen song auf mein album das heißt icon
und da geht es um einen häftling im
gefängnis also ich trete man auch in
gefängnissen auf und
und der hat so langen bart und wann sehr
ausgeglichener mensch das ist das kommt
nicht vor wie so ein krimineller und
er hatte der wollte mir unbedingt seine
zelle zeigen dann bin ich mit ihnen zu
seiner zelle und die war voll gestapelt
mit gruppen er war ikonenmaler geworden
er hat lebenslänglich bekommen ich weiß
nicht wofür aber im gefängnis hat er so
eine conversion erlebt bonus ist mensch
geworden und so eine ikone wird über
drei monate lang gemalt und gebetet und
meditiert und er ist dann nach seiner
zeit nach griechenland geplanten in ein
kloster und dessen mensch geworden und
hat dabei die ikone gemacht das sind
redemption stories die mich inspirieren
als songwriter weil da ist jemand der
etwas böses getan hat der diese welt so
furchtbar machen der schwere krebs sich
wendet und auf einmal den rest seines
lebens in buschehr bringt wieder gut
machen und mit gebeten mit fasten mit
opfer- und
das sind so sachen wir müssen wir das
thema wechseln weil ich merkte dass ich
weiß werden
das kann nicht so weitergehen
also ich meine sind aber und das ist
wichtig zu erwähnen dass da sie ein
kritischer geist sind auch in religiöser
hinsicht sie haben als einen titel in
ihrem neuen album und das ist erstmal
ein abschnitt aus diesen
[Musik]
doch was
ja sind wirkliche berührender bewegende
starke zeilen auch in diesem song drin
so etwas wie wer bist du dass du das
licht
tötest
worum geht es in diesem song was drücken
sie hier zum ausdruck bringen jaffé sei
es ein song über den missbrauch von gott
oder religion als rechtfertigung für
gräueltaten ja also sei es im
christentum oder im islam oder in
anderen religionen
man sieht immer wieder situationen oder
menschen die website
also die bösesten schlimmsten dinge
anrichten und mir war es einfach wichtig
auch ein ja mir war es wichtig ein paar
sit protest song zu schreiben denn auch
den missbrauch von ihnen von der
christlichen glauben einfach beleuchtet
also ich hatte ein ich hatte in
südafrika eine begegnung mit einem
jungen mann dessen vater ja überzeugt
von der apartheid ideologie war und
furchtbare dinge gemacht hat und dann
hatte eine begegnung mit nelson mandela
und ist komplett ein anderer mensch
geworden er ist arzt und seitdem
verbringt er seine ganze zeit damit als
arzt ohne grenzen quasi in dörfer zu
gehen wo menschen sich kein arzt leisten
können und sie umsonst zu behandeln als
wiedergutmachung
weil er wirklich schlimme dinge getan
hat und das ist ein thema in der
zweiten strophe und der erste strophe da
geht es um diese umerziehung schulen und
programme von staat und kirche in kanada
und usa wo man die american native pippo
versucht hat in ihre identität zu
brechen also kilwi indien entscheidet
war ein programm ein slogan und
die haare mussten gekürzt also klamotten
alles alles was so identity war musste
gebrochen werden um eine christliche
identität eine weiße identität hinein zu
zu zu stampfenden stumpf also dass das
sind sachen da sage ich das ist so ein
widerspruch mit das was ich unter
christlichen glauben verstehst du nicht
ist es eine befreiende religion und ich
glaube es gab kein mensch keine person
die freier war als jesus christus ich
meinen jemand der sagt the way of life
wenn du da ich jetzt wenn sie oder ich
auf wenn sie ihre ich hier in zürich in
der fußgängerzone gehen will und sagen
so ich bin das licht der welt oder ich
bin der weg die wahrheit und das leben
die wir uns einstellen
jesus hat das gesagt und da gibt es
einfach eine entscheidung hat weder er
schwimmt oder er spricht die wahrheit
und
aber ja fitness sa ist ein song der darf
ich sie gerne bei denen bei dem zitat
dass sie jetzt erwähnen sehen sie da
auch nicht eine kritische punkt dort wo
er dann dadurch auch andere ausschließt
wenn er der weg ist und die wahrheit
dann kann kein anderer der weg auch ein
weg und auch eine wahrheit sein
also diese leute missbrauchen gemacht
ich ja definitiv
also ich glaube das ist eine sehr gute
frage also kirkegaard hat mal gesagt
es gibt so viele menschen hat gesagt
dass es so viele wege zu gott gibt wie
es menschen gibt glaube schon dass der
weg zu gott ein individueller ist ein
persönlicher ist ich glaube aber dass es
ein gott gibt und nicht viele götter
oder jeder macht sein gott das ist ja
dass ich meinen und genau wie es
wahrheit gibt also es gibt subjektive
wahrheit aber auch objektive wahrheit
also
subjektiv empfinde ich sie diesen moment
hier anders aber objektiv erleben wir
beide diesen moment wissen sie was ich
meine und so versteht es auch in der
religion und glauben dass es das ist
eine wahre also dass es einen wahren
gott gibt und leider
respektieren wir unsere
unterschiedlichen auffassung nicht immer
und dominieren mit unserer meinung die
anderen und darum geht es auch in diesem
song famous sei also das ist für mich
nicht mehr sein dass da ist erlösend und
das ist bindend und des leidenden
menschen bis heute unter diesem
konsequenzen weil die letzten
umweltschulen die gab es ja noch in den
fünfziger und sechziger und das ist
grauenhaft was da gemacht wurde und wir
sehen auch schon tief in ihren dritten
leben drin
und das ist auch richtig so eigentlich
sind sie von anfang an derjenige der
über all das reflektiert des dreifachen
phase wir haben die die erste phase des
lebens hat eine phase beschrieben
die eben keine rhythmen kannte die
zweite phase ist aber eher eine phase
die mit vorgegebenen rhythmen data
vonstatten geht und es ist ja bewegen zu
hören wie sieht aus diesen beiden
rhythmen an ihren eigenen rhythmus
gewinnen konnte dann freien selbst
gewählten selbstbestimmten mich
interessiert vor allem die
rolle ihrer frau
und zwar deshalb weil ich mich frage wer
ist sie in ihrem leben ist sie die
familie
die familie ist sie ihr kloster
ist sie
rückzugsort ihre musik
und jetzt dürfen sie ihre
liebeserklärung
jetzt haben sie mich in der ecke
eigentlich spreche ich sehr wenig über
mein privatleben aber ich sehe die ganze
zeit darüber also alle meine lieder sind
ja voll von meiner von von der liebe
meines lebens ja
ich versuche ihre frage zu beantworten
ohne zu viel privates von hier zu geben
ja also ich glaube wenn man einen
menschen
findet der einen liebt sie wer man ist
dann ist es sehr viel wert und und das
ist würde ich sagen einer der qualitäten
meiner frau dass sie mich in und
auswendig kennt mit allen versagen und
schwächen des alltags auf der bühne gebe
ich immer mein bestes
wenn denken die leute war der ist immer
toll aber zu hause kriegt gibt es auch
mein worst of
man hat ja bei so einem konzert auch
wahnsinnig viele hormonausschüttung
endorphine wobei ich kann also aber zu
hause hat man dann die morning after ist
man wie so ein hannover ja und also das
ist mir war es wichtig jemand zu zu
finden die mich liebt für wer ich bin
und nicht für das was ich mache ja also
ob ich erfolg habe oder nicht ob ich in
der öffentlichkeit stehe oder nicht
sondern diese tiefe identität die ich
bin
und und das ist das ist so schön wenn
man das hat im leben
und ja also
meine frau ist nicht geschenk des
himmels ich kann sich anders erklären
dass es nicht merkt findus und einem
match made in heaven
und es gibt sicher auch beziehungen die
durch kinder entsteht müssen wir sind
aber ich hab was anderes gemacht und bin
sehr dankbar für diesen ja dieses
gegenüber was nicht sieht und liebt wie
ich bin vergibt auch es gibt eine schöne
schönen spruch eine gute ehe besteht aus
zwei vergebenen menschen weil man muss
sich ja auch vergeben versagen für
fehler für
short cummings
sie sind auch jemand der sich auch als
ein friedensaktivist begreift auch in
diesem dritten leben wir haben auch die
sendung mit dem klang einer glocke ja
anklingen lassen
ich frage mich ob wir es wagen sollten
etwas zu machen was so selten gemacht
wird nämlich sie sind auch bekannt als
mystery man schreiben dieser viele texte
sie haben ganz berührende art auch so
singen und menschen zu bewegen ich frage
mich woher kommen diese texte was halten
sie davon dass wir zumindest ein zwei
stufen hier live versuchen hin zu
bekommen war
ich bin ihr angeles
und sie können einfach
vielleicht bei den frieden okay war ihre
fußball was wäre etwas was einen song
geben kann was sonst ein prosa gespräch
nicht die kraft dazu hat auch schon weil
sich schreiben dadurch auch gedichte
oder dann vielleicht können wir das
zusammen machen oder weil ich brauche in
der regel sehr viel zeit für texte wenn
man zu zweit sind kriegt was vielleicht
in zehn minuten irgendwas
was mich in der tat im unterschied zu
ihnen weiter etwas vorbereitete daher
ich hab's ja bewegt die geschichte die
sie hier erzählen nämlich aus dem was
kriegerisch benutzt wird das ganze
umzuwandeln und das eigenhändig zu
machen ich fragte mich das müsste man
doch das ist doch ein motiv ein motiv
das uns zeigt frieden ist nicht etwas
weil sie erklären frieden ist etwas was
wir machen ja auch gestalten dann warum
nicht so etwas wie kam in for peace wird
johanns
und form frieden
also die piste idee ist tatsächlich die
der transformation also im ersten und
zweiten weltkrieg wurden um die 150000
kirchenglocken beschlagnahmt um mit
diesen metallen waffen herzustellen und
ich habe diesen prozess umgekehrt ich
habe krieg schrott also aus granat
hülsen von werder und so dass
eingeschmolzen und eine psp
gegossen uns ziemlich groß und die wird
bei den konzerten immer
ja geläutet um eine friedens minute
einzuleiten und das ist ein sehr sehr
starker moment wenn zehntausende
menschen kurz die klappe halten und alle
schweigen und das ist das eine wahnsinns
kraft die man da in der luft spürt wenn
alle einfach innehalten und und das ist
etwas was ich auch immer wieder bei
meinen konzerten mache und das ist
sowieso sagen die kleine piesberg
und ja das ist
sind wir es ist möglich leben zu
schaffen
es gibt viele projekte die ich
unterstützen also präventive projekte
aber auch post bohrprojekte
nur ausreden warum ich die strafe nicht
so nein wir waren ja bei den gedichten
verzeihung ich habe einmal
kommen aber zurück zu wird es wird ja
wie wäre es wenn man ich finde fri
ich habe versucht mit der psp was
haptisches was hörbares zu schaffen weil
trieben klingt immer so abstrakt ne also
wenn ein krieg ist dann weiß jeder was
fehlt sogar wenn kein krieg ist dann so
man kann von inneren frieden sprechen
von gesellschaftlichen politischen
frieden sprechen aber vielleicht könnten
wir
frieden
personifizieren also dass wir einen
domain namen geben so
helden
oder wie wäre es denn wenn
wenn der frieden uns anspricht was man
es so dreht so wenn ich denn ich der
chef der welt wählen also the world so
dann gäbe es das dass das nicht und oder
ethisch since the beginning of tara been
around and around erste bilder dateien
also mich gibt's schon seitdem ist die
zeit gibt so
aber wie online knie oder sowas oder ich
weiß nicht was mir weil ich fand das
sehr schön was sie vorher meinten dass
es ihnen schwerfällt an einen gott zu
glauben der mensch wird wenn menschen so
böse sein können und aber jesus wurde
auch abgelehnt wurde auch ans kreuz
genagelt und und kamen die welt als
licht der welt und man wollte dieses
recht nicht das hat ein gestört sein
vielleicht kann man darf es nicht geben
er ist der frieden in uns nicht geben
darf geht es immer schon gegeben hat
dass man sie oder ist das ist schön oder
wollen sie lieber auf mein transform hat
sich ihren gegnern auch gerade ein
angesprochener zufrieden zu sein die
perspektive ist sehr berührend ich sehe
michael patrick kelly vor 10.000
menschen berg aber hinzieht und mit mit
einem gesunkenen was eigentlich sonst
der kleinen so etwas hat als ein
angesprochener des friedens
das lied nicht so ende machen können
aber das ist ein open prozess jetzt
etwas was also in diesen tipps st da
gibt es eine zeile kanalnetzes und das
ist ja ein bisschen so diese
transformation so man nimmt aus etwas
woran eine materie die menschen
zusammenbringen sollte für friedliche
ereignisse und dreht sie und macht
daraus ein instrument des tötens die
menschen auseinander reißt und wir
nehmen das noch mal diese wahl und
trommeln ist zu einem breit aber das
gibt es schon aber dieses kam
also ich finde schrieben schließt man
mit dem feind nicht mit dem freund und
frieden muss auch nicht immer heißen
alles ist gut wir verstehen uns liegen
ist wegen des green
toleranz ist ja auch nicht alle sind
herzlich und alles ist harmonie sondern
toleranz heißt das ausharren aushalten
was einem nicht passt also
kompromiss politik ist ja voller
kompromisse
[Musik]
oder
lassen sie uns das so im stillen weiter
spinnen sagen
sie sie haben auch in diesem boot sind
ihre
cd aufnehmen neuesten album
wahre geschichten erzählt und man der
letzte frage wäre welche story welche
geschichte
wollen sie einst selbst
eine musikalische oder eine gläubige
ich hoffe eine wahre eine wahre
geschichte ob als gläubiger als man
mensch christ
wahrheit setzt mich frei und und ich
glaube wir leben in einer zeit wo man
von einer krise der wahrheit sprechen
kann das wirklich
die gleiche realität wird von
verschiedenen seiten völlig anders
gesehen verstanden und dann entstehen so
weit aber
ich versuche eine wahre echte
authentische mensch musiker christ zu
sein
und es ist nicht immer einfach es
braucht mut weil es ist einfach wichtig
sachen schönzureden oder in wunschdenken
zu verfallen oder zu lügen also ein
mensch liegt im schnitt 1 bis zehnmal am
tag ja es kann durch lüge sein ist keine
plant leiser und aber ich habe gemerkt
immer wenn ich lüge oder gelogen habe
das ist das hat nur zu dass sie das wort
scheiße geführt oder zu
weiß nicht als als künstler gehört
einfach ja es ist also in einer
beziehung zum beispiel wenn lügen und
spielt sind das dauert nicht lang das
gibt wenn die hose also vertrauen kann
nur entstehen wenn wirklich man
wahrhaftig miteinander umgeht und und
von daher ja es wäre schön wenn ich
irgendwann meine zeit hier hinter mir
habt dass man vielleicht sagt
war jemand der die wahrheit gesucht hat
und versucht hat wahrhaft zu sein so ich
möchte nicht als hero dargestellt werden
weil ich kann nicht so gut das bin ich
nicht
dank vielen dank für das bewegende und
inspirierende und frisches sprich
dankte ihm spaß gemacht
[Gelächter]
ja ich wünsche ihnen einen wundervollen
und hoffentlich auch musikalisch und so
trägt
[Musik]